Joe Harris has a career 42.7 three-point
percentage in over 1,000 attempts of
those who have attempted more than 1,000
three-pointers only Steve Kerr Hubert
Davis Steph Curry Jason Kapono Steve
Novak Kyle Korver and Steve Nash rank
higher than Joe Harris who joins us now
Joe good morning how are you good
morning
did you know that stat that year I think
eighth on the all-time list of guys who
have attempted at least 1,000
three-pointers no I did not know that
it's pretty good pretty good company in
there oh definitely when did you find
out you were getting new teammates
I mean I say they had an idea obviously
the day of free agency and but it all
came together pretty quickly and
everybody just happened to be actually
in New York so you know soon as day time
6 o'clock we had a little uh you know
sort of get together
that's a facility that everybody
probably but it definitely all came
together pretty abruptly okay wait so KD
and Kyrie were there and you guys had a
little social event and at the arena no
no no at our practice facility okay so
what what was served we actually had
that Clive Owens came in and success was
the first nice nice I like that and so
did you introduce yourself into Kyrie
and Katie I did to Katie but I played
with it was Kyrie before okay okay so
I'm Katie I'm Katie and you you are
waiting to come up now how do you do
that I mean pretty standard introduction
nothing okay so you didn't you weren't
stumbling for what is the right thing
hey I'm the three-point shooting contest
champion or it wasn't anything like that
no no I did I didn't start off that
pretty
pretty standard what was the mood like I
mean everybody was obviously it's not a
good our entire coaching staff for an
office ownership you know it's a
monumental moment for the organization's
obviously everybody's excited most of
our guys are back to one of the guys
that are gonna be around next year so
you know a lot of excitement pretty
surreal you know it's again it's crazy
just more quickly everything sort of
came together yeah be kind of getting
you know you want to be excited and say
hey let's go out and play and then you
got Katie limping around so that's kind
of a buzzkill so you guys couldn't go
out and say hey let's go play some
pickup situation but you know obviously
you know he's arguably one of the best
players to ever play the game
and even if he's out a year I mean he
still just happy to have him a part of
the organization he's Joe Harris his
nickname is Joe he's Joseph Joe and
bring that up I know
wait I have to because when we're going
which what's Joe Harris's nickname and
fritzy goes ah Joe I go come on come on
we got to bring Joey hoops or or beef
jerky Joe or Joe the gunner Joe I'm one
of the great shooters of all time like
something in there Joe if you ever seen
a beer does enough I know but the beard
gave you a little bit of an identity but
not in Brooklyn because everybody has a
beard in Brooklyn I know now I'm just a
mobile you know I'm an everyday hipster
at Brooklyn huh and by the way McLovin
net has challenged you to come out on to
I was waiting yeah where were you I just
I saw a tall guy with a beard but there
was like four Joe are you afraid of
McLovin hey I I said yeah the first time
I was of the show ha I'm ready to go
down there and shoot whatever you guys
were just kind of waiting on the call
well it's kind of made plans with Kyrie
now that he's
okay didn't you go on vacation with
D'Angelo Russell yes I went to
materiality okay
in that kind of weird and then here you
are he gets you know sent to Golden
State like hey we're vacationing
together he's my teammate and the next
thing you know he's in Golden State yeah
I mean see how this mean you know you
build up close relationships like in any
profession when hear what people long
enough said you know you're sad to see
people go but it's in problem you know
it was a part of the business but you're
happy for him he obviously landed in a
great spot got an unbelievable deal and
you know I know he's excited about it
who's your best friend in the NBA my
best friend any um I would say I mean
I'm probably close with Matthew
Dellavedova I was in his wedding a
couple of years ago and we we got really
tight over in Cleveland together I want
a piece of Dellavedova delis the man is
he's an all time guy he's just really
got I I want ten chances against
Dellavedova one-on-one yeah
hey we could I mean we could line that
up at the pier as well I'm sure he could
what am I making a trip to hang out in
New York for a weekend so I'll shoot
again stick a little bit and then you
can play one-on-one against Delhi yeah I
mean I know if I shot against him I
would win but I figure if we're gonna
just do one on one and Benelli delis
gonna give me that fake hustle does he
slap the concrete when he's playing
outside Joe did he slap the floor during
his vows when he got married I was kind
of surprised that you got some heat when
you were got dunked on by LeBron back in
2018 there's a lot of guys have been
dunked on by LeBron why did you get
grief you know that's myself the
question what is that feeling like
though when you
no you're in no man's land and LeBron is
going up and then you're just kind of
caught yeah I mean it was a lot of
situations I really there's just a
matter of sort of inertia and then you
get posterized and I'm like wait you
know they're making fun of him you got
dunked on thinking
LeBron's dunked on hundreds of guys yeah
it could be on this I would put my who
have you dunked on anybody I don't know
who thought actually let's buy my only
person everything's done somehow I
managed to do it but do you think that
might have been one of those where he
turned around late and then you were
already getting ready to dunk on him and
then or was it a blatant hate I'm coming
at you I think it's one of those things
where you know you see me coming down
the middle and you're assuming I'm just
going to go and waiting and somehow I
you know propelled myself almost using
his body to get a little bit okay a much
minor Tom Chambers that's one of the
great dunks of all time or Tom Chambers
on Mark Jackson yes that was filthy what
were you guys doing with Russell Wilson
a couple of days ago yeah he was in town
played at the festival and he has a good
relationship with our ownership group
Joe side his wife Claire and he just
came into use absolutely just to train
for a couple of days and he ain't good
to be a bunch of us for ongoing working
out is he any good at basketball we
didn't get him in on the court
we we tried to about my he was faced
with he's staying sane with us and
swinging retro
do you guys are you guys playing any
pickup games over the summer are you
allowed to yeah August a plumber but one
home visitor you know planning family
and getting ready for that right now I
wasn't playing a lot here lately
if KD and Kyrie ask for recommendations
where to live what would you tell me I'm
a Brooklyn guy so I'll recommend
Brooklyn but you know obviously pretty
easy for guys to get into our facilities
whenever - the Barclays if they want to
live in Manhattan - yeah I think that
they're probably Soho kind of guys
Tribeca I would I would I would go
against that either
you know maybe Kyrie and KD just get
like a two-bedroom yeah I mean I'm down
yeah you could put up like one of those
fake walls in between would you let them
stay at your apartment yeah I mean of
course that's what makes our four yes
yeah is you know college teammates you
might be crashing that way I'd be funny
though you KD Kyrie now that'd be a good
reality show you produce some good
content yes yes mclubbe don't forget
that wacky neighbor McLovin running in
and saying oh yeah so I live in McLovin
I live in Dumbo
oh I see your than me but I think that
you and Mick love and I'll let you guys
work on this Joe but he does want a
piece of you and his team just one hour
three-on-three League here so it was you
might google it the American Athletic
Association of America has McMuffins
team one and he was the MVP all right I
knew that I was not being so so
challenging I started you know you have
everything that works out Joe you have
everything to lose here nothing to gain
is a good point yeah I'm still down
before I love it hey enjoy the offseason
there Joe and there'll be a few more
people on that Nets bandwagon yeah
for a while yes I have been you know
like four months but that feels like an
eternity
thank you Joe there you go that's a Joe
Joseph Joe Harris on the program for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]